this is Eric swalwell now Eric swalwell
we know had a relationship with the
Chinese spy McCarthy has said this
multiple times and you know it's true
because if it wasn't true the mainstream
media would be going after McCarthy but
they're not so it is true he has talked
to people at the FBI he said it on my
show a year and a half ago but he's
repeatedly said it since he's been house
leader but anyway Eric swalwell Democrat
congressman from California here he is
freaking out over the release of the
tapes and it's fairly obvious because
it's just what you just said James he
knows there's something there
well what we're seeing uh week by week
that now Kevin McCarthy has to pay a new
installment on that corrupt bargain
right so last week the installment was
to give Tucker Carlson unfettered access
to police footage sensitive police
footage of the capital on January 6. you
know there's no good ending to that uh
it's it's either going to be used to
distort what happened on January 6th uh
by Tucker Carlson or you just gave the
proudest boy of all a blueprint for the
capital uh that you know perhaps who
knows where that will land you know for
the next Insurrection that could be
planned
all right I really despise this guy I
mean I I at this point hate a lot of
people in government but this guy I mean
the implication he calls him the
proudest boy of all somehow that Tucker
Carlson is either a white supremacist or
something like that the point I really
want to draw out from that clip was that
comment you regarded either that you
brought up where he he regarded Tucker
Carlson as the proudest boy of them all
and so this is that appeal to the proud
boy so I'm gonna gonna do a call back to
something I mentioned earlier which is
that book beautiful trouble which is
available online for free I think
anybody wants to understand leftist
activism needs to go read it you're not
a serious player in what's happening if
you haven't looked at beautiful trouble
another one of their core principles is
your Target's reaction is your real
action so by provoking Society through
the things that happened in 2020 through
the things that have happened since
through the drag queens they get this
organization to come into formation
called The Proud boys the proud boys
show up to things they act in a you know
quietly or modestly or sometimes not
intimidating manner they're an auntie
anti if you will in opposite a
dialectical opposite of antifa and they
have become that is a reaction to the
provocations of BLM antify et cetera
that have been happening drag queen
Story Hour that have been happening
throughout the country those are
provocations they're strategic
provocations this is unconventional
warfare and they have generated that
reaction and listened to what they do
with it it comes up every single time so
when you react badly when you act react
the way that they want you to react they
are weaponizing you for their narratives
for the different tools that they're
going to use for the justification to
you know have to shut things down or
control speech or control thought or
control whatever so proud boys became an
emblem in that it's the reaction and you
can actually say if you understand the
principle in beautiful trouble that that
reaction was exactly the thing that they
needed just like the event in j6 was
exactly the thing that they needed even
though it wasn't because it didn't pan
out the way that they could have really
used it to drive a narrative that
something's happening in this country
that's the opposite of what's really
happening there was an insurrection on
January 6th I know there was an
Insurrection on November 3rd or whatever
it was previously you know so they cover
up their own Insurrection with the fake
Insurrection they cover up the fact of
antifa violence with and drag queen
Story Hour provocations drag queen
performances for children and now babies
apparently everywhere with well the
proud boys are violent and we have to
resist this anti-lgbtq hate blah blah
blah blah and so that understanding that
they are provoking reactions and using
reactions that's what Greta does she
provokes a reaction she fake gets
arrested puts it on a camera
understanding that this is a fundamental
objective a fundamental tool of their
activism that keeps moving the ball for
them allows us to figure out ways to
short-circuit that and sidestep it if
you'd like more sane takes on our insane
World check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live roundtables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell